oh [ __ ] when [ __ ] Milwaukee
bound uncle Joey getting ready to
welcome the walk because that's how I
[ __ ] do it
BAM mad [ __ ] flavor here in
full effect
with his new Boris lubinski head dude
what are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
uncle Joey here and [ __ ] him no walking
I got my wallet I got the joint of life
I don't know what time it is like 7
o'clock who gives a [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
time to smoke a joint somewhere you
understand me I got my Starbucks coffee
here
I'm gonna say a lot of the day together
[ __ ] that's how we roll
[Music]
get a little appetite going for the
[ __ ] morning
[Music]
I'm a fat [ __ ] but when I get up in the
morning and I know appetite you
understand me so I'm gonna smoke the
[ __ ] bone I gotta write a little bit
I gotta get all ready
then I go to breakfast we do whatever
the [ __ ] it is I gotta do
[Music]
but we're here with we're
visit the weed that killed dr. Spock
and many other Reapers I'm Hannibal
walking my main man Matt full-time when
doing a pageant see you tonight
seven o'clock be there or be square is a
couple tickets left Chicago come on up
[ __ ] Detroit come on up because it's
so got down Adam on
my [ __ ] around I'm saying
I had a good night's sleep me and my man
full trauma for a steak I had a nice
[ __ ] sleep
now I'm up tip top Magoo and ready to go
Matt homier all my boys are here
I got do a little writing a little radio
[Music]
and I think it will not be known a
little workout for tonight and then
we're ready at the past blue-ribbon
[ __ ] theater whatever the [ __ ]
[Music]
like a [ __ ] doctor you understand
Cali Milwaukee Connecticut hey don't
[ __ ] matter
we create our [ __ ] party understand
we make our own [ __ ] happy out
here's my [ __ ] happy out right here 7
a.m. little Caulfield wreath or maybe a
nicotine gum paint pam-4 poop
and I said we burnt one
we're gonna burn a couple throughout the
[ __ ] day
so that we are one [ __ ] Reaper day
today so if you're not planning to
smokin reefer change your [ __ ] plans
there's an uncle joey's world what
puffin from dawn to dusk or dusted or
whatever the [ __ ] the situation is
[Music]
besides that you know I love you
[ __ ] thank you for supporting
the church both of them are ready for
you I passed out this week it's a good
episode
and that's it and that's that it's time
to get the [ __ ] day going powder your
nut shine your shoes and get out there
and Friday [ __ ] do it time
Friday do you do it today or you can't
[ __ ] do it you gotta wait till next
week so I suggest you do it [ __ ]
today
because remember at the end of the day
they're gonna suck your dick today or
they're gonna suck your dick tomorrow
what they're gonna suck your dick the
shoes that you got those type of powers
instead
[Music]
but beside that I'm ready for the day
and I say yes you get your [ __ ] together
- I'll check in with you [ __ ]
later
same bat-time same bat-channel see what
the [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna go eat some
breakfast and get the day started I love
you [ __ ]
don't forget about me and see you
tonight at the patch divas seven o'clock
bring the [ __ ] stars bring the
Gorilla Biscuits
but you know me I'm ready to [ __ ] go
tonight Milwaukee Nazis Jeffrey Dahmer
if somebody rocked your [ __ ] city like
uncle Joey tonight be there or be square
right stay black